aujourd'hui je vais vous parler d'un
très joli smartphone je vous avais déjà
parlé d'autres jours ce que j'étais à
londres sur le lancement c'est le
honneur 20 alors il ya quelques temps au
nord a sorti en pleine crise
huawei en pleine crise contre les us 1
au nord vingt et un au nord 20 pro est
ce que je me suis dit c'est que lors de
la présentation le haut-rhin pro elle
est complètement étouffé le hors vins et
on a les traits peut en entendre parler
et bien comme quoi des fois le malheur
des uns faisant le bonheur des autres
enfin je bosse on peut réellement dire
ça comme ça mais en tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est que commencer poser la
question de savoir si les honneurs 20
prend aux lettres homologué d'ailleurs
il est on aura très bientôt dresse le
dans vingt projets à sortir avec une
licence android donc ça c'est une très
très très bonne nouvelle d'ailleurs
j'avais dès maintenant pour nous tes
aucun test et pour ne pas louper le test
du au nord d'un procès à vous abonner
dès maintenant vous y allez vous cliquez
alesi ou d'activer la cloche les
notifications la compet comme ça vous
saurez tout et d'ailleurs je vous invite
également à me laisser un joli pouces
bloc comme ça se font appeler
comptabilisé pour savoir si vous aimez
mon travail non pas pour le produit mais
pour mon beau allez on y va on s'abonne
pouces bleus je vous laisse trois
secondes 1 2 3 merci beaucoup
vous êtes des amours joulane alors
justement le nord 20 euros comme il a
été décalé comme il ya peu le suspense
justement de buffet dans la
certification android et bien ça a
permis de les synthés peu d'oxygène à
ceux au nord 20 était sorti il n'y a pas
très longtemps qu'on savait que lui
justement avec la certification il
allait sortir fin juin ce qui d'ailleurs
est le cas lui au nord 20 et là le nord
un projet toujours pas là donc ça permet
de parler duo d'orvin de pouvoir ré
expliquer ce qu'est ce produit s'il est
bien oui ou non justement avant que le
no 20 promet vole la vedette parce que
je pense c'est ce qui risque de se
passer c'est une bonne chose on en
reparlera d'ici quelques temps alors
c'est normal il est bien il est
vachement intéressant mais aussi
quelquefois qui sont un peu pas bloquant
mais un peu difficile vu la concurrence
parce que vous savez qu'on est quand
même ce renseignement pris un peu moins
de 500 euros et sur ce segment de prix
là vous avez concurrence qui est énorme
avec plein d'acteurs de tous les côtés
que ce soient des acteurs chinois des
acteurs coréenne datant tous les côtés
même docteur america donc ça devient
extrêmement compliqué ce qui est bien
pour le consommateur ça fait beaucoup de
produits à pouvoir choisir un grand
panel de produits puis c'est pas
toujours simple de savoir lequel acheter
pourquoi quoi comment il faut vraiment
se poser la question de ce que vous
voulez et donc juste
ce hors vins il a des trucs qui sont
vraiment cool vraiment intéressant mais
la première chose que je propose
si on va faire un petit peu un tour du
produit comme ça vous allez pouvoir le
voir de près presque par le de sentir le
toucher en tout cas moi je le sens de
toute la ligue où il est là il est beau
il est chaud on y va let's go
[Musique]
petit aparté
si vous saviez comme j'ai hâte qu'on
soit la rentrée non pas que je sois très
content que les vacances passe vite mais
j'ai vraiment hâte parce que je vous
concocte plein de choses plein de
nouveaux formats plein de nouveautés
j'ai vraiment de pouvoir les partager
avec vous je pense qu'on va vraiment se
faire plaisir on va aller encore plus
loin faire plein de nouvelles choses ça
va être super cool fun plus abonnez-vous
comme ça vous serez tous dès la rentrée
en attendant ce moment grâce et de
féliciter voici le au nord 20 l'année
dernière j'avais beaucoup aimé l'honneur
dix c'est vrai que c'était un très bon
produit qu'on arrive vraiment bien bossé
sur ce produit là donc là une fois de
plus on a un produit qui est vraiment
cool vraiment intéressant avec ce ce dos
avec un effet un peu holographique
quadruple caméra à l'arrière pour autant
son côté ici votre bouton de volume sont
150 radars et là vous avez un bouton
pour l'allumer qui est également le
capteur d'empreintes digitales et qui
marche parfaitement bien il déverrouille
extrêmement rapidement c'est pour moi
une très très bonne idée de l'avoir
positionner là je préfère d'ailleurs que
des constructeurs viennent imposer un
capteur d'empreintes digitales un petit
peu standard ici plutôt vous a posé un
capteur optique qui va marcher un peu
moins bien qui sera un peu moins rapide
donc ça pour moi c'est un très bon choix
de la part de honor vous retrouver en
dessous ici un haut parleur mono votre
branchement usb pour recharger le micro
pour la réduction bruit ici votre
emplacement pour votre double carte nano
sim si vous le souhaitez micro pour la
réduction bruit de l'infrarouge et voilà
on a fait le tour alors à l'avant je
crois que ça vous aura pas échappé
on va se retrouver avec cette petite
caméra ici qu'on voit très bien en
attendant les caméras qui arriveront
très bientôt qui seront complètement
intégrées cacher sous l'écran au centre
pour l'instant on a cette solution-là
qui malgré tout n'est pas pire c'est pas
la meilleure ne cache pas c'est parce
que je préfère ce sont encore des des
petits pop up qui vous libère
complètement l'écran néanmoins ce une
solution qui pour l'instant n'est pas
mal du côté de la boîte on va acheter un
ticket rapidement se sentent simple
efficace petit design blanc avec le
produit qu'on voit que tous les côtés au
nord 20 au nord vers le nord en voyant
le droit c'est très joli
lorsque vous ouvrez bon votre smartphone
normalement et là là de quoi l'ouvrir
vous avez intérieur votre câble usb usb
c'est via lamont qu'aucun votre
blog de charge huawei superbe c est un
bloc de 25 watts pour le recharger assez
rapidement et vous avez un petit
adaptateur parce que sur le produit
n'est pas de prise jack 3.5 donc là je
vous avais un adaptateur usb c'est jack
3.5 pour venir écouter de la musique
alors ça je trouve pas ça extrêmement
parfait pour moi c'est un peu
l'accessoire a oublié vraiment vraiment
vraiment vraiment le vouloir je
conseille quand même d'acheter un casque
bluetooth pour ça et en plus que vous
avez d'ubuntu 5.0 donc ça marchera très
bien dans une collection qui sera plutôt
bonne là par contre en voyez vous chez
votre truffe blanche est votre cas ça va
peser c'est lourd c'est pas beau c'est
pas pratique voilà pour moi ça c'est
vraiment le l'accès soit vraiment si
vous le foie mais sinon pour moi ça il
faut l'oublier
pour moi le honneur 20 il fait plusieurs
promesses le premier point c'est l'écran
le deuxième point ce sont les
performances qu'il ne me dites pas que
j'écris mal je le sais le troisième
point c'est l'autonomie et le quatrième
point c'est la partie photo c'est pour
moi le focus principal ça va être
compliqué tout les tenir
il va falloir être à la hauteur
notamment par rapport à ce qu'on trouve
en face à la concurrence une fois de
plus mais où va la regarder un parent
qui vous me direz vous en commentaire ce
que vous en pensez
premier point l'écran vous avez à
l'écran lcd cette hyundai i ps 6,26
pouces de diagonale résolution 2340 par
1080 pixels qui occupent 80 11,7 pour
cent de la face avant
c'est pour moi un écran qui est vraiment
bien qu'ils aient bien maîtrisée de la
part de honor là dessus les choses que
je vous recommande quand même c'est de
venir dans affichage led en mode des
températures vous voyez sur couleurs
vives
si vous n'êtes pas par défaut et là vous
n'en faites vous m les couleurs chaudes
par défaut vous êtes comme ça c'est un
petit peu violine je trouve ça pas
terrible vous pouvez soit venir le
module et vous directement ici selon vos
goûts vous pouvez faire sinon vous venez
directement vous cliquez sur chauny si
ça va venir un petit peu jauni à votre
écran mais ça va casser un peu l'effet
lumière bleue passera plus confortable
plus sympa et pour moi c'est là tu vois
vraiment le meilleur résultat au niveau
de votre écran cet écran je trouve
vraiment bien pour me regarder du
contenu multimédia
il est sympa jetèrent prochain petit peu
ce petit rond qui vient cacher votre
appareil photo
après lorsque vous le tenez comme ça
c'est pas forcément très très grave mais
c'est vrai que c'est pas quelque chose
que j'ai particulièrement affectionner à
côté de ça je trouve que la colorimétrie
est assez juste les contrats sont justes
l'écran est bien et ça c'est vraiment
gros point positif pour moi moi j'ai pas
un peu regretté là dessus par contre
c'est lo jo vous avez juste un haut
parleur qui se cache ici ce qui va me
gêner plus haut parleurs c'est donc un
peu de puissance
le but
pour inonder - c'est la performance ce
smartphone est très performant il marche
très très bien vous avez ce qui se fait
de mieux du côté de chez huawei honor
c'est un kirin 980 qui marche
parfaitement mais c'est solide qui
équipe notamment le paie 30 pro bête de
compet couple est assis giga de ram ça
marche parfaitement bien en plus d'un
point de vue logiciel vous avez le gpu
3.0 qui va lui permettre d'aller encore
plus vite de tout optimisé d'un point de
vue matériel logiciel c'est vraiment une
bécane qui est hyper optimisé qui va
très bien à cela vous ajoutez 128 go de
stockage non extensible ceci étant dit
c'est pas un état grave
100 naturel de stockage pourraient quand
même déjà faire beaucoup de choses
mettent beaucoup d'eau à l'intérieur
beaucoup de contenu avant d'être dépassé
donc ça pour moi pour les performances
la promesse est largement tenu troisième
point et non des moindres c'est la
partie de l'autonomie je sais j'ai la
main axa sur la tête bien évidemment
alors l'autonomie est somme toute assez
correcte mais l'autonomie c'est
tellement fluctue en fonction de ce que
vous allez vous en faire pour moi
l'autonomie elle est bonne vous avez une
grosse batterie de 3750 meilleur terreur
vous avez changé très rapidement grâce à
la superbe charge mange bien c'est cool
c'est efficace enfin c'est pas la
recharge la plus rapide du monde
néanmoins elle est assez rapide a fait
le job board smartphone vous allez le
garder allumée entre une journée à deux
journées ça va dépendre de ce que vous
allez en faire une journée et demie
aller on coupe la parole de paf
pour moi ça va ça marche bien il ya un
bon boulot qui a été fait là tu seras
cup on aurait pu s'attendre à voir une
batterie un peu plus mon corps aussi un
peu plus gonflé une batterie 4000 milles
et antérieures ça m'aurait paru normal
d'autant plus qu'on a ça sur l'honneur
view va donc on dit pourquoi sur les
honneurs 20 broom et une batterie un peu
plus petit allez savoir
choix stratégique en tout cas pour vous
d'un point de vue purement performances
vous sentirez pas particulièrement je
trouve que c'est un smartphone qui se
tient bien donc ça c'est cool
dernier point et non des moindres qu'en
est il de la partie photo ça pour moi
c'est l'élément principal de ce
smartphone c'est vraiment ce qu'on va
venir chercher parce que des smartphones
performants mais il y en a beaucoup des
smartphones avec des encoches ici il y
en a beaucoup des smartphones sur lequel
vous allez avoir quatre capteurs photo
dans ce segment de tarifs
il y en a pas des masses et ça c'est
pour moi très bien c'est toute la
promesse et toute la foi en tout cas de
ce produit vous avez donc un capteur
principal de 48 mégapixels et ouvre à f
1.8 c'est la sony mx 5 186 si vous êtes
habitué à des tests vous savez que ça
sony emi
586 j'en ai énormément parlé d'ailleurs
le premier smartphone quelle équipe est
un smartphone de honor c'est le honor
yuv 1 en début d'année c'est une caméra
qui va vous faire des photos s'ils
voulaient avec un capteur de 48
mégapixels qui vous fera une photo en 12
mégapixels pas la peine de sortir une
photo en 48 mégapixels vous auriez pas
un gain énorme par contre ce qui est
vachement bien c'est que notamment sur
le mode nuit vous allez prendre 4 pixels
ça me transformer en un seul et même
pixels offre un très gros pixels comme
ça tu auras capter plus de lumière et ça
vous permettra alors les photos beaucoup
plus sympa en mode nuit et en plein jour
ça marche parfaitement bien donc très
bon capteur ça c'est cool vous avez un
deuxième capteur sont ultra grand-angle
16 mégapixels ouvre à f 2.2 un ultra
grand-angle 217 degrés et en bas là
cachés ici vous avez deux capteurs tous
les deux sont des capteur de 2
mégapixels une ouverture de f 2.4 le
premier servira pour le mode portrait
ici et le deuxième pour la macro je
voulu tout de suite la macro c'est du
gadget vous n'allez pas faire souvent
des photos en macro
si vous aimez la macro c'était un
amoureux de la macro vous prenez un
boîtier numérique
vous prenez un bridge ou pour les
quelque chose pour aller vraiment faire
de la macro des smartphones pour ça
c'est vraiment du gadget
le résultat est assez marrant vous allez
le voir positionné à 4 cm mais au-delà
de ça bon voilà il n'y a pas grand chose
à faire avec et à l'avant vous êtes une
caméra ici cassé dans ce petit trou
comme on l'a vu depuis le début de 30 2
mégapixels une ouverture de f 2.0 je
vais pas garder le suspense bien
longtemps
l'intérêt ce smartphone c'est sa
polyvalence vous faire des photos de
nuit avec un très bon capteur ça marche
parfaitement bien des photos grand angle
ça marche un peu moins bien je vais vous
montrer pourquoi dans quelques instants
de photos au mode portrait avec les
facebook et ça marche aussi parfaitement
bien le mode macro et bien la caméra de
cette fille est très honnête tout ça est
très bien on va lui reprocher néanmoins
ce qu'on retrouve très souvent chez au
nord c'est à dire des lissages qui sont
souvent un petit peu trop prononcé on
aime on n'aime pas néanmoins je vous
montrais quand même ce smartphone tient
des promesses mais pour moi la promesse
numéro un c'est le quadruple capteur
photo ici ça c'est cool
à moins de 500 euros et ça croyez moi
c'est vraiment une très jolie promesse
pour moi le rendu est hyper qualitatif
on est sur le capteur principal la
caméra de 48 mégapixels que ce soit au
niveau du détail que ce soit au niveau
de la lumière comme moi d'une très très
très bonne gestion là dessus que les
photos également prises dans les mêmes
conditions juste à côté ça marche
parfaitement bien et si photo normale
avec le
x 2 et là avec le grand angle je trouve
que le rendu colorimétrique est quand
même beaucoup moins efficace beaucoup
moins sympa il ya un côté un peu flou
sur la photo le point n'a pas été fait
là le point était fait plus derrière
donc pour moi c'est pas terrible et en
plus c'est quand même relativement
déformant photos prises avec le capteur
principal
il ya un bon équilibre des couleurs la
gestion de la luminosité du détaillant
rooney messi petit fils d'araignée était
probablement 16 ou une fois 2 qui
fonctionne encore le petit fils d'avoir
sur le côté au delà du détail ça c'est
vraiment bien
hélas le grand-angle une fois de plus je
trouve que la couleur générale est
beaucoup moins sympa la luminosité est
beaucoup moins belle il ya un effet vous
allez un peu de suspense a tout de suite
beaucoup moins qualité ils sont aux
prises avec le mode macro qu'il
fonctionne en mode macro là le point
était fait un peu moins efficacement ça
très sympa avec le mode macro va
vraiment la transparence avec la lumière
c'était assez sympa bonne macro et
également photos prises avec le capteur
principal thomas jolie petite piscine
accueille presque 40 degrés extérieurs
croyez moi ça fait beaucoup de bien
là avec le zoom x 2 et là avec le grand
angle là on sera un peu moins compte de
l'effet déformant vu qu effectivement la
piscine et en pareil cas l'auteur
principale ville x 2 et lille fragmente
en bref tout de suite beaucoup plus pâle
le point est fait je ne sais où c'est
pas terrible chercheur principal x 2
jutras grand temps pareil c'est flou
devant et là on est en mode macro
regarder ça alors on a bien le veinage
je trouve que le rendu est quand même
assez sympa et assez cali pouvoir
compter sur un smartphone
là on est sur la caméra selphy avec une
belle tête de vainqueur en pleine
canicule c'est pas dingue mais ça fait
le job et là on le dirait peut-être pas
mais avait pas beaucoup de lumière dans
la pièce qui est pris de photos sur un
pied en mode nuit et ça marche
parfaitement bien regarder le rendu sur
le visage du bonhomme un donald qui vous
embrasse elle son petit doigt sa
tactique là comme ça voyez ça je trouve
que ça marche vachement bien et j'ai la
même photo qui est prise dans les mêmes
conditions mais pas avec le mode nuit
regardez il ya moins de détails c'est
beaucoup plus flou c'est là où on voit
toute la force de frappe du traitement
logiciel au niveau de ce mode nuit ça
marche vachement bien alors j'ai utilisé
aussi une bonne nuit sur un ultra grand
angle
c'est beaucoup moins précis beaucoup
moins sympa ça marche mais tout de suite
c'est quand même vachement intéressant
au niveau du mode portrait ça marche
bien alors on a la puissance de calcul
d'un grec le quirinal 980 le détourage
est assez bon au niveau des cheveux
c'est exactement ça alors j'ai des
gouttes d'eau jeux perles sur le fond
parce qu il fait une chaleur absolument
incroyable ici et là j'ai poussé un
petit peu le traitement et le lissage à
regarder le visage
on dirait que
18 ans s'est glissée cheli c'est alors
c'est assez efficace mais malgré tout
c'est quand même un petit peu fake est
ce que les promesses qui sont faites par
au nord sont tenues au niveau de l'écran
oui pour moi à l'écran est de bonne
qualité il est bien bien calibré vous
serez absolument pas déçu les
performances ont juste excellente avec
le charisme 980 le gpu 3.0 et compagnie
ça marche très bien
l'autonomie est bonne on aurait pu
espérer un petit peu mieux mais sans les
rassure la version pro il faut forcément
aucune différence entre le modèle
standard il modèle pro on en parle si
quelques temps si vite de plus à dire
vous abonner comme ça vous saurez tout
et la photo est bien la photo et bien
oui mais pas sur l'ensemble des capteurs
l'offre pour moi à quatre capteurs fond
elle est pas extraordinaire
ce qui est très bien c'était principal
48 mégapixels qui est parfaitement bien
maîtrisé que cela ne pose du matériel ou
d'un point de vue logiciel c'est top ça
marche parfaitement bien l'ultra grand
angle sert globalement pas grand chose
le rendu est pas très qualitatif c'est
déformant ce n'est pas très beau je
pense que c'est oublié par contre ce qui
est assez sympa c'est ce petit mode
macro même si on va pas l'utiliser
souvent c'est un petit gadget sympa donc
bon je dirais que en fait on aurait
juste deux capteurs là dessus on aurait
eu un peu moins un effet whaou mais en
aurait en tout cas de capteurs qui
marche très bien une belle combinaison
ensemble donc sonore 20 je le trouve
bien trouve que au nord a bien bossé
pour voir qu'on est sur un smartphone à
un petit peu moins de 500 euros c'est
bien 499 euros pour être très précis
d'ailleurs si vous intéresse venez un
lien en bas dans la description vous
pouvez y aller ne vous inquiétez pas
pour la question de la licence android
toute façon il y aura des mises à jour
qui seront faites
et là on est sur un dénouement de
l'histoire huawei donald trump amérique
ça devrait plutôt bien se passer je
pense que huawei et va avoir ses
distances ou pour continuer à sortir des
smartphones sur android sans absolument
aucun problème c'est plus tard de mettre
la pression et dire regardez c'est mal
boss voilà c'est un peu ça l'idée
donc vous pouvez y aller sans aucun
souci et sans vous poser de questions là
dessus pour moi c'est un smartphone qui
écoule ses smartphones qui est
intéressante non le bémol que j'ai c'est
qu'en est il par rapport à la
concurrence je sais qu'en fait vous avez
notamment un google pixels 3a webxl 3 à
ixelles qui sont vraiment excellents en
termes de photos avec un seul capteur
vous avez les iphone si ce qu'on va
tester d'ailleurs dans quelques jours
qui est intéressant notamment sur le
fait d'avoir un seul et même grand écran
dans sas et c'est plutôt cool
il ya beaucoup de monde en face il ya
beaucoup de produits aussi le mit
de schumi c'est vrai que c'est compliqué
mais si vous voulez un smartphone qui
fait de bonnes photos avec un écran
hockey et que le fait d'avoir la petite
encoche de vente vous pose pas de
problème et bien pourquoi pas pouvez y
aller parce que pour moi vous ne serez
pas déçus au nord de maîtrise son
produit l'eau et c'est bien c'est magic
to wake qui tourne sur un android 9
paille c'est cool ça nage étaient bien
voilà a vous de me dire ce que vous en
pensez en bons commentaires comment vous
le trouver d'ici quelques temps va
arriver le test du au nord 20 pro on en
reparlera sur feu doux fait des gros
becs et je vous dirai demain ciao bisous
[Musique]